on commence avec le mot du jour
lipothymie c'est le diagnostic fait par
les médecins du président de la
république
la lipothymie est un malaise sans perte
de connaissance il n'y aurait donc pas
lieu de s'inquiéter pour nicolas sarkozy
le président a pu quitter l'hôpital en
fin de matinée avec une seule
prescription le repos et pas de footing
pour quelques temps frédéric roth à loïc
de la mornais anthony serre c'est vers
11 heures du matin que le président a
effectué sa sortie
main dans la main avec carla bruni
sarkozy son épouse il tient devant les
caméras à saluer et remercier le
personnel médical qu'il a suivi ces
dernières 24 heures nicolas sarkozy
était arrivé hier par hélicoptère du
parc de versailles où il avait fait un
malaise pendant son jogging
un petit geste à l'intention des
journalistes et des badauds massés à
l'extérieur de l'hôpital militaire
et puis sans faire la moindre
déclaration le couple s'engouffre dans
la voiture officielle
direction la résidence présidentielle de
la lanterne à versailles
dans la foulée un communiqué de l'elysée
fournit une explication médicale
il s'agirait d'un malaise lipothymique
d'effort soutenu et sans perte de
connaissance
une annonce qui met un point final à
certains petits couacs en matière de
communication hier l'entourage avait
évoqué un malaise vagal et puis ce matin
au siège de l'ump
on va même jusqu'à évoquer un problème
un peu plus sérieux si personne ne
considère qu'un accident cardiaque est
une alerte qu'est ce qui peut être une
alerte
quelques minutes plus tard le porte
parole de l'ump se ravise et laisse aux
seuls médecins le soin de qualifier ce
malaise en l'absence de tout traitement
médical c'est un repos relatif dont a
besoin le président mais si l'on en
croit son premier ministre il n'a pas
vraiment l'intention de tout arrêter
lié à un effort physique important sous
un soleil intense
je me réjouis c'est cet après midi de
retrouver en grande forme qui ont
travaillé avec lui car la prochaine
sortie attendue de nicolas sarkozy c'est
mercredi prochain pour le dernier
conseil des ministres de l'année alors